[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat pour notre émission
spéciale consacrée au 105e congrès des
mares de France organisé par l'AMF
l'association des maères de France
jusqu'à jeudi Public Sénat mobilise
toutes ses équipes pour vous faire vivre
l'événement avec des débats des
reportages et les temps forts des tables
rondes de ce congrès et comme chaque
année la première journée est consacrée
aux élus d'outrem et à leur
problématique sur le terrain des élus
ultramarins qui sont reçus au Sénat par
gerérard Larché le président du Sénat
avant en échange sur l'avenir de la
commune cet après-midi
d'échange je tiens à le souligner est un
moment
privilégié pour mes collègues et
moi-même qui partageons ce même
attachement à la
proximité cet attachement au territoire
et en particulier aux 212 communes
ultramarines
disséminé à travers le monde et qui
contribue par la même au rayonnement de
notre
pays mais peut-il en être autrement
alors que le Sénat incarne votre voix la
voix des élus locaux qui assure la
cohésion de notre
République votre présence et vous êtes
nombreux il va falloir qu'on
utilise des mzanines me semble-t-il oui
votre présence nombreuse est source de
satisfaction
je voudrais saluer les présidents
d'association de Mair qui jouent tout au
long de l'année un rôle important dans
leur territoire à travers les conseils
qu'ils apportent aux communes les temps
d'échange qu'ils organisent et leur
fonction indispensable de relais auprès
des parlementaires en outre grâce à
l'heureuse initiative du président David
Lisnard ils peuvent désormais au sein de
la délégation outrem de l'association
des maires de France uvrer en faveur de
leur territoire auprès des décideurs
nationaux les thèmes retenus pour cet
après-midi d'échange surt l'avenir de la
commune et du ma et l'enjeu de l'eau ces
sujets sont particulièrement d'actualité
tant dans l'Hexagone que dans vos
territoires ils ont fait l'objet d'un
travail approfondi du Sénat et des
préconisations concrètes ici de rapport
de deux missions d'information leurs
auteurs Marie scarer et Mathieu Darnaud
pour le prier terme ainsi que Rémy Porou
et Hervé Gillet pour le second je crois
que ils ne manqueront pas de vous faire
part de leur
réflexion de leurs analyses et de leurs
propositions s'interroger sur l'avenir
de la commune et du maire apparaît comme
une exigence et je le dit devant la
présidente de la délégation collectivité
territoriale du Sénat Françoise Gatel
particulièrement engagé elle aussi sur
ce sujet depuis plus de 15 ans
nous vivons une
recentralisation et par la même un
affaiblissement de la liberté d'action
des élus durant cette période nos
communes ont perdu une grande part de
leur autonomie financière depuis la
suppression de la taxe professionnelle
puis de la taxe d'habitation ou encore
c'est en cours de la cotisation sur la
valeur ajoutée des entreprise pour
certaines d'entre elles je pense aux
communes de Polynésie française de
Nouvelle Calédonie son la dem moi la
situation est encore plus
complexe pour ce qui est de la liberté
d'action puisqu'elles dépendent de par
leur statut du financement de l'État et
du transfert du budget du
territoire je souhaite que le futur
statut de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie actuellement en
discussion conforte les communes
calédoniennes notamment en matière
budgétaire car elles sont un échelon de
proximité indispensable au développement
harmonieux de la société calédonienne et
à la consolidation du vivre ensemble
sujet essentiel du débat nous en
reparlerons bientôt dans le cadre de
notre groupe de
contact en Polynésie française les
délégations de compétence du fois au
commune et le rôle de ces dernières
mériterait d'être revu afin de les
renforcer en évoquant la polie française
je n'oublie pas le souhait des élus des
îles Marquises ils me l'ont
signifié de profiter d'une prochaine
révision constitutionnelle pour
permettre la création d'une communauté
d'archipel au pertes d'autonomie évoqué
s'ajoute de nouvelles craintes suscité
notamment par l'annonce d'une prochaine
réforme en profondeur je reprends les
termes mêmes de la première ministre de
l'octroit de mer
important pour les collectivités qui le
perçoivent une telle annonce doit nous
incité à la plus grande vigilance
lorsque l'on sait que cette aut croix de
mer rapporte plus de 1,5 milliards
d'euros aux collectivités
concernées aussi ai-je demandé au
rapporteur général du budget de
constituer un groupe de travail avec nos
collègues de la commission des finances
très au fait de ces questions et ce en
lien avec notre délégation aux
outrè nous avons pleinement conscience
de l'importance des conséquences
éventuelles de cette réforme pour vos
territoires car l'roit de maire en plus
d'être une ressources majeures s'avère
être un outil important l'accompagnement
de la production
locale le Sénat a toujours été présent
sur ce dossier comme le monent les
travaux de notre délégation en 2020 je
les rappelle et notamment en travaux en
faveur de son maintien je pense qu'il le
sera tout aussi attentif aujourd'hui et
demain outre ces difficultés et ses
craintes l'État et le Parlement doivent
tenir compte des situations financières
assez dégradé de beaucoup de vos
collectivités qui ne permettent ni
l'investissement local ni le plein
emploi des crédits budgétaires qui leur
sont alloués je le dis devant George le
dispositif Corum dont nous avons
toujours soutenu le principe ici au
Sénat est un bon outil pour créer dans
les collectivités en difficultés une
dynamique qui conduise à la
vertu il convient donc d'élargir ce
dispositif me semble-t-il et d'augmenter
les crédits qui sont alloués même si ces
derniers ont progressé afin que plus de
communes puissent en
bénéficier il est me semble-t-il
regrettable que ne permett pas
d'accompagner plus les communes dans
cette trajectoire progressif de retour à
l'équilibre par exemple j'ai constaté
qu'àotte une seule commune aujourd'hui
une seule commune Sada en est
bénéficiaire ça ne peut que m'interroger
car j'ai le souvenir de ma rencontre
avec les Mair de maot et des difficultés
j'en vois ici présent devant moi quelle
rencontre nous voyons bien le bloc
communal duose de moins en moins de
marge de manœuvre dans un contexte de
plus en plus tendu lié à une
augmentation de charg sans précédent il
est donc indispensable
d'instaurer une véritable autonomie
financière et fiscale des collectivités
avec un panier de recette clair en
cohérence avec les compétences et les
charges des collectivités c'est
d'ailleurs l'une des propositions du
groupe de travail sur la
décentralisation mise en place l'an
dernier avec les représentants de tous
les groupes politiques du C
pour redonner aux élus locaux le pouvoir
d'agir je le dis devant les deux
rapporteurs Mathieu Darnaud et Françoise
Gattel sous l'autorité du président de
la commission des lois au problème
financier que je viens d'évoquer
s'ajoute des faiblesses en terme de
formation du personnel c'est un sujet
d'ailleurs qui m'a frappé dans ma
dernière visite en Guadeloupe et en
Martinique ce sujet a été fort
porté par les élus tant en
administration de gestion qu'en
management ou en conduite de projet là
encore François Gatel dans un rapport le
monte pour les communes polynésiennes
mais cette problématique il me paraît
qu'elle se retrouve dans les commune des
Trois Bassins géographiques il convient
dès lors de développer les compétences
au service de l'action locale mais aussi
d'améliorer les dispositifs de soutien
en matière d'ingénierie et notamment
ingénierie de l'État je trouve
intéressante la proposition de nos
collègues de la commission des lois qui
après s'être rendu dans cas des
territoires de l'arcantillet Guadeloupe
Martinique Saint-Martin Saint-Bart ont
souhaité que l'assistance technique de
l'État notamment par l'entremise de
l'Agence française de développement
puisse être utilisé pour former oui
former dans les collectivités
bénéficiaires les personnels à
l'expertise technique nécess au plein
exercice de leur mission judicieuse
également la proposition de généraliser
au sein des collectivités des
plateformes d'appui en ingénierie sur le
modèle de celle mise en place en Guyane
avec les moyens humains et bien sûr
financier nécessaire face à ces constats
au fond nous voulons un état local
accompagnateur et facilitateur et non
pas simplement censeur
pour cela il faut renforcer les services
de l'État dans les préfectures leur
redonner les moyens financiers humains
justifié par la situation de vos
territoires et en fait rétablir ce
binôme maire préfet ou maire au
commissaire aux difficultés liées à la
perte d'autonomie financière et à la
faiblesse des compétences s'ajoute une
autre contrainte que vous connaissez
bien que nous connaissons tous
l'inflation normative face à celle-ci
les élus se sentent de plus en plus
paralysés dans leur capacité d'action
d'autant qu'elle a un impact financier
important sur nos collectivités je
rappelle le dernier chiffre du président
Lambert qui estime le coût au niveau
national des nouvelles normes en 2022 à
2 milliards et demi d'euros pour
l'ensemble de nos collectivités
territorial de plus ces normes
nationales ne sont pas toujours adapté
aux contraintes particulières de vos
territoires je pense spécialement aux
normes en matière de construction et de
logement ce constat d'une adaptation
insuffisante des politiques publiques
aux spécificités de chaque territoire
ultramarin me paraît faire consensus
encore faut-il maintenant qu'on fasse
bouger du consensus il faut passer à
l'action l'inadaptation concerne aussi
bien la conduite des politiques
publiques que le cadre normatif Stéphane
Artano l'avait rappelé avec Michelin ja
dans un rapport sur l'avenir
institutionnel des Outremers le besoin
de différenciation renforcé est affirmé
partout les élus un exemple parmi tant
d'autres j' reviens nous l'avons dit
l'an
dernier l'AV la c est un avis conforme
en areem alors que c'est un avis simple
dans l'Hexagone je pense que cette
question elle mérite vraiment d'être
posée et reposée encore cette année dans
cet esprit à la suite d'échanges avec
les exécutifs locaux des recommandations
formulées au cours des différents
travaux de la délégation aux outremè je
souhaite que soit déposé et inscrit à
l'ordre du jour du Sénat une fois par an
une proposition de loi d'adaptation du
droit des outrmèes c'est dans le projet
que j'ai proposé pour le Trien qui vient
de s'ouvrir ce rendez-vous annuel en
plus de renforcer les liens entre le
Sénat et les collectivités ultramarines
permettrait de mieux associer les élus
de ces territoires à l'élaboration de la
loi et obligerit les administrations des
différents ministères à être plus
réactive en matière en raison de son
institutionnalisation cette manière de
fabriquer la loi aurait en outre le
mérite de limiter le recours aux
ordonnances dont nous pensons qu'elle
aujourd'hui est un recours
abusif je souhaite que le Sénat joue
aussi un rôle central dans le processus
d'adaptation je viens de l'évoquer mais
aussi de contrôle du gouvernement sur la
mise en place des décision du comité
interministériel des outres mèes en vue
duquel chaque territoire a pu
transmettre les difficultés qu'elle soit
normative qu'elle soit budgétaire ou
organisationnelle qu'il
rencontre dans le même esprit en réponse
à l'appel de fort- de- France la
délégation aux outremes a préconisé
trois pistes de
réflexion première piste le statut C
constitutionnel mais qui ne saurait être
synonyme d'immobilis puisqu'il serait
accompagné d'une révolution de
méthode deuxè piste là où c'est souhaité
une modification des articles 73 et 74
de la Constitution afin de mettre à la
disposition des outromèes de nouveaux
outils en particulier pour les
collectivités demandeuses je parle bien
demandeuses
trè piste un cadre constitutionnel
entièrement rénové assimilable à une
boîte à outils au sein de laquelle
chaque outreire pourrait choisir ce qui
lui convient le mieux dans le cadre
d'une loi organique qui serait donc
faite sur
mesure ces scénarios nous les traiterons
lors d'une réunion spécifique du groupe
de travail institution qui se réunira le
13 décembre prochain je le dis en
février le sén son rapport sur les
questions
institutionnelles sujet abordé par le
Président de la République dans sa
campagne électorale pour lequel il n'y a
pas eu de réunion
annoncé
trans partisan ou transgroupe politique
mais au Sénat depuis maintenant un an
nous y travaillons et nous rendrons
notre rapport au mois de février
prochain dans cette période de multiples
défis votre rôle d'élu est fondamental
car vous incarnez je reprends le thème
du congrès de l'an dernier le pouvoir
d'agir ainsi le Sénat a voulu
repositionner les maires au cœur de nos
institutions en leur consacrant par
exemple un véritable statut de l'élu
permettant de mieux concilier vie
professionnelle personnelle et mandat et
surtout en vous protégeant davantage
protéger je pense je ne sais pas si dans
cette salle que je pense à Blaise mornal
maire de petit canal en Guadeloupe qui a
fait l'objet d'une agression il y a peu
et bien la proposition de loi que nous
avons voté renforçant la sécurité des
élus locaux et la protection des maires
a été voté le mois dernier à l'unanimité
de notre assemblée c'est dire que nous
souhaitons vraiment vraiment euh
protéger ces élus deuxè temps fort et
j'en ai presque fini concerne l'enjeu de
l'eau
dans plusieurs territoires d'outrem les
coupures d'eau les infrastructures
défectueuses les sous-investissements
les problèmes de gouvernance les
inégalités d'accès à l'eau la dépendance
au PL génère à la fois la montée d'un
sentiment d'injustice au sein de la
population de fort mécontentement face à
des situations qui durent malgré des
moyens significatif mis en œuvre ces
situations
sontant plus difficile à tolérer que les
prix de l'eau vont du simple au triple
entre la Réunion où elle est la moins
chère et la Guadeloupe où elle est la
plus
chère je reprends le rapport du Conseil
économique social et
environnemental j'en parlais vendredi
dernier avec le président du C l'eau
toujours selon le rapport peut également
représenter jusqu'à 1/3 du budget j'ai
demandé à vérifier pour un ménage
modeste à
maotte je pense que T Mohamed SW et sa
Omar wali pourront nous le confier et le
confirmer ces difficultés concernant la
distribution de l'eau ne doivent pas
obérer un autre objectif prioritaire qui
doit nous mobiliser celui de la mise en
conformité des installations
d'assaainissement qui par leur véuseté m
en danger la santé humaine et
l'environnement solidarité nationale
doit jouer je soutiens la proposition de
notre mission d'information qui
préconise pour davantage de justice
territorial un soutien financier
spécifique aux offices de l'eau
ultramarin et la relance de la réflexion
sur la solidarité
interbassin
voilà comme vous pourrez le constater au
cours des échanges à venir le Sénat se
veut à votre écoute il a
particulièrement à cœur de représenter
vos collectivités dans le respect de vos
diversités et de votre histoire alors je
vous souhaite de fructueux débats et je
suis convaincu que cette journée doit
pouvoir répondre à vos attentes et puis
je vous invite à l'issue de vos travaux
à nous retrouver au pavillon de
l'Orangerie pour un moment de
convivialité ce sera quand même bien
mérité après cet après-midi de travail
et mon trop long discours mais je
voulais vous dire quelque chose
d'important
ici les communes des outre mère c'est
quelque chose d'important c'est pas 212
parmi 35000 c'est quelque part le modèle
communal qui peut être un modèle de
vivre ensemble de proximité de relation
avec les citoyens et c'est me
semble-t-il ce don nous avons le plus
besoin dans notre pays dans sa diversité
aujourd'hui voilà pour cette première
partie et on va passer à la première
séquence et je vais maintenant présenter
nos intervenants bien évidemment pour
commencer nous aurons les propos
productif merci d'accueillir
chaleureusement le nouveau président ou
la nouvelle présidente comme vous le
souhaitez de la délégation outremaire
madame la sénatrice Micheline Jacques
merci de l'accueillir
chaleureusement toutite sénateur de
saint-bartééi à vos côté je fais les
présentations monsieur le sénateur
Mathieu Darnaud sénateur de l'Ardèche
premier vice-président du Sénat
président la délégation du bureau du
Sénat en charge du lien avec les
territoires et des consultations des
élus et des citoyens désolé pour la
longueur du titre membre de la
délégation autres Mair rapporteur comme
l'a dit le président de la mission
d'information sur l'avenir de la commune
et du maire euh et à vos côtés madame la
sénatrice Catherine concon sénatrice de
la Martini merci de l'applaudir
chaleureusement j'entends pas les voilà
secrétaire du Sénat membre de la
délégation du bureau du Sénat en charge
du lien avec les territoires et des
consultations des élus et des citoyens
membre de la délégation autr mè voilà
vous pouvez encore l'applaudir parce que
je crois qu'on a loupé des et Françoise
Gatel sénateur dilet Villen président de
la Délégation aux collectivités
territoriales à la décentralisation
merci aux premiers intervenants vous
pouvez les applaudir et je vais
inviter le nouveau président de la
délégation tromire à faire le propos
introductif merci beaucoup
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues Mesdames et Messieurs les
maires et les élus mesdames messieurs je
suis particulièrement heureuse de vous
hier cet après-midi au Sénat pour cette
4e rencontre dédiée au maire et élu
d'outr maire au nom des membres de la
délégation sénatorial aux outremè que
j'ai l'honneur de présider depuis peu je
vous souhaite à la suite du président
Gérard Larché qui nous a fait cette
année encore l'honneur d'ouvrir cette
rencontre la bienvenue dans la maison
des collectivités territoriales
c'est-à-dire en réalité la vôre je tiens
aussi à remercier l'Association des
maires de France et son président David
lissnard avec avec laquelle nous nous
coordonnons pour organiser cette belle
journée des outremèes nous avons à
nouveau souhaité nous mettre à votre
écoute directement et sans filtre afin
d'entendre vos préoccupations et les
faire remonter priorité au dialogue au
regard coroisé et au témoignage de
terrain en organisant ce rendez-vous la
délégation est fidèle à son ADN comme
vous le savez notre délégation est
chargé d'une triple mission une mission
d'information du Sénat sur les questions
relatives aux AR maire une mission de
veille pour la prise en compte des
caractéristiques de chaque collectivité
et une mission d'évaluation des
politiques publi les concernant pour
illustrer mon propos je ne peux manquer
de citer les nombreuses études et
recommandations faites par un autre
délégation au cours de la précédente
session en matière de gestion des
déchets de continuité territoriale de
fonciers agricole et d'aide à la
parentalité nous avons été force de
propositions et dont le suom a fait sien
nombre d'entre elles
en matière de continuité territoriale
tout particulièrement ma collègue
Catherine Conconne qui a été la
rapporteur de ces travaux ne me
contredira pas nous avons obtenu des
avancées significatives le projet de loi
de finances pour 2024 traduit l'effort
budgétaire obtenu du gouvernement
naturellement cela ne signifie pas qu'il
ne nous faut pas aller plus loin encore
en matière de politique du logement
aussi notre rapport de 2021 a très
largement nourri les propositions du
SIOM sur cette enjeu si important pour
nos territoires et vos communes en
particulier notre délégation est de plus
en plus attachée à donner des suites
concrète à ses travaux y compris sous la
forme de proposition de loi au cours des
prochains mois conformément au vœux
exprimés par le président Larché nos
travaux sur les institutions nous
conduisent à souhaiter que l'État
révolutionne ses méthodes et son
organisation un état profondément
déconcentré doté d'une agilité normative
outre M et de plus en plus impér pour
répondre à l'aspiration unanimement
partagée d'une coconstruction des
politiques publiques sur nos territoires
c'est afin d'approfondir cette voix
indispensable que notre délégation a
décidé de lancer dans les prochaines
semaines une mission d'information sur
les modalités d'action et d'organisation
de l'État dans les outrmèes deux temps
forts vont donc rythmer cet après-midi
un premier portera sur l'avenir de la
commune et du maire je remercie très
sincèrement notre collègue Mathieu
Darnaud vice-président du Sénat pour
avoir accepté d'ouvrir cette cette
séquence nos collègues Catherine Cancon
membre de la délégation et secrétaire du
Sénat et Françoise Gattel présidente de
la délégation aux collectivités
territoriales apportteront également
leur regard sur ce sujet dans une
seconde séquence nous avons choisi de
débattre de la crise de l'utre mer la
situation dramatique et inédite de l'eau
à Mayotte et dans toutes les têtes et
semble à peine concevable sur un
territoire de la République publique
française mais par- deà ses facteurs
propres cette crise après celle de la
Guadeloupe qui persiste interroge tous
nos territoires sur l'impérieuse
nécessité de sécuriser la question de
l'eau sans laquelle aucun développement
harmonieux n'est possible je remercie
chaleureusement notre collègue RV gilet
rapporteur de la récente mission
d'information du Sénat sur la gestion
durable de l'eau de prendre part à nos
échanges voici ce que je souhaitais vous
dire en brève introduction avant de vous
souhaiter à tous d'excellents travaux et
de fructueux échanges je vous remercie
merci infiniment madame le Président
merci beaucoup alors place avec votre
collègue Mathieu Darnaud le premier
vice-président du Sénat qui a
fait un rapport sur la mission
d'information sur l'avenir de la commune
et du maire et qui va nous parler de
l'avenir de la commune et du maire c'est
à vous monsieur le
sénateur merci monsieur le Président du
du Sénat et je salue l'ensemble des
collègues
vice-président président prident de de
délégation et l'ensemble des collègues
sénatrices et sénateurs je n'oublie pas
celles et ceux qui sont à l'honneur à
savoir les les présidents d'association
de maires et l'ensemble des maires
ultramarins qui nous font le le plaisir
d'être parmi nous aujourd'hui au Sénat
alors effectivement nous avons commis il
y a de cela quelques semaines puisque
nous avons rendu au président du Sénat
ce rapport sur l'avenir de la la commune
au début du mois de de juillet dernier
la volonté était relativement claire sur
la portée de de ce rapport ce rapport
visait d'abord à à prendre en compte une
situation qui est finalement et c'est
vrai autant sur le territoire
métropolitain que sur les territoires
ultramarins un mandat tout à fait
singulier où s'exprime malheureusement
plusieurs phénomènes le premier d'entre
eux c'est et le Président il a fait écho
c'est le phénomène de violence auquel se
trouve confrontter l'ensemble des élus
le second il est peut-être aussi un peu
singulier parce que que il tient
finalement d'une d'un particularisme sur
ce sur ce mandat avec la la mise en
place des des nouveaux exécutifs
communaux dans un temps où nous avons
été frappés par par la crise sanitaire
et puis tout simplement parce
qu'aujourd'hui et les élus que nous
avons auditionné autant élu ultramarin
que qu'élu métropolitain nous l'ont tous
dit et finalement c'est le point commun
à ce rapport c'est les difficultés
aujourd'hui au qu vous êtes toutes et
tous confrontés difficultés qui peuvent
être d'ordre
financière difficultés qui sont liées
aussi à des rapports parfois complexe
avec avec l'État parfois un manque
d'agilité parfois un manque de de
réponse aux aspirations que que vous
porter ou encore difficultés que vous
pouvez rencontrer notamment lorsque nous
sommes venus en Martinique et en
Guadeloupe avec le président du Sénat
cela a été évoqué avec des
intercommunalités émer gente qui ont
parfois du mal à trouver un mode de
fonctionnement satisfaisant et qui
parfois mériterait à être revisiter
c'est encore la le sujet de la
sanctuirisation finalement de la commune
au-delà des des
212 communes que que vous représentez
aujourd'hui la commune c'est quelque
chose autant en métropole qu' outre
maire qui est plus qu'un simple échelon
administratif plus que ce terme qu'on a
tendance à utiliser l'échelon de base de
la démocratie locale c'est aussi le
creuser des solidarités c'est ce lieu où
se tisse finalement l'ensemble des des
solidarités finalement ce ce ce lieu qui
fait encore sens pour nos concitoyens et
on le voit même s'il n'est pas épargné
par le le le le phénomène démocratique
avec une mobilisation de nos concitoyens
qui n'épargne pas la commune et qui se
trouve être en baisse mais pour autant
cela reste l'échelon euh qui est
largement plébisité par l'ensemble de de
nos concitoyens ultramarins comme comme
métropolitain alors pour se faire et je
vais essayer de faire œuvre de concision
parce que le temps qui m'est imparti est
relativement court euh mais je sais que
vous aurez à cœur d'avoir un un un
échange sur l'ensemble de ces sujets le
premier euh des thèmes que nous avons
souhaité aborder c'est finalement la
sctuirisation de la commune avec un
versant constitutionnel il est deux
sujets qui sont pour nous essentiels le
premier de ces sujets c'est d'inscrire
dans la Constitution la clause de
compétenence générale il faut à la
commune quel qu'elle soit où qu'elle se
situe et j'inclus dans mon propos les
communes de Polynésie et les communes de
Nouvelle-Calédonie d'ailleurs le fait
d'avoir un débat et de porter ce ce
sujet sur le versant constitutionnel
nous permettra peut-être d'avancer et je
me tourne vers mon collègue de de de
Nouvelle-Calédonie et ma collègue de mes
collègues de de poli poinésie d'avancer
sur ce sujet essentiel qui est
finalement le statut de la commune sur
ces territoires et plus généralement
avec l'ensemble des autres territoires
faire en sorte que l'on reconnaisse la
commune comme un échelon tout à fait
particulier un échelon à part eu égard à
ce que je viens de dire le deuxième
phénomène et alors là aussi il est
commun à l'ensemble des territoires
c'est le fait d'ériger en principe
suprême dans la Constitution la le le
principe suivant qui décide paye ou qui
paye décide parce que là c'est un point
commun que vous rencontrez chacune et
chacun dans vos territoires c'est que
très souvent que ce soit l'état
territorial ou l'État central vous
répondez en permanence jour après jour à
des injonctions et à des transferts de
charges qui sont parfois déguisés ou ou
apparents et malheureusement vous n'avez
plus au fil du temps les moyens de d'y
répondre et les moyens de faire en sorte
que les injonctions les souhaits de
l'État puisse trouver une concrétisation
sur vos territoires communal donc
inscrire ces deux principes qui pour
nous sont la
garantie de protection absolue de la
commune autant comme lieu particulier
cher au cœur de nos concitoyens mais
aussi comme cellule de base de la
démocratie je je je l'évoqué à l'instant
qui a cette agilité et qui permet de
répondre aux plus proches aux besoins de
l'ensemble de de nos concitoyens et je
crois que dans un temps particulièrement
compliqué auquel se trouve confronté
notre notre pays mais beaucoup d'autres
pays la commune c'est aussi une des
réponses aux aspirations de nos
concitoyennes et de nos concitoyens le
deuxième sujet c'est le le rapport à
l'état aujourd'hui c'est une réalité
absolue et d'ailleurs nous avons voulu
un petit peu changer de paradigme nous
nous considérons que le temps est venu
de parler de territorialisation de
l'action publique comprendre par là le
fait que chaque territoire et le
président du Sénat il faisait référence
quand il parlait de la différenciation
territoriale chaque territoire à ses
propres atouts à ses propres faiblesses
à ses propres ressources et il est
peut-être temps plutôt que d'essayer de
modéliser d'appliquer en tout lieu et en
tout point du territoire un modèle de
regarder finalement la vérité à l'onne
de chacun et des territoires
métropolitains ou ultramarins je le dis
parce que c'est important c'est une
nouvelle façon de penser le territoire
mais qui met au centre du jeu encore un
peu plus la commune et nous avons
largement plaidé pour que les femmes et
les hommes qui représentent l'état sur
nos territoires puissent avoir cette
capacité à lire le règlement ou la norme
on a beaucoup parlé de l'inflation
normative puisse le faire avec une
souplesse qui permette de répondre au
spécificités de de nos territoires on
évoquait tout à l'heure et chaque année
votre service ur dépose par rapport à ce
que disait le le président sur la
question des CDP NAF un amendement pour
qu'on aligne justement le régime des
communes ultra marin sur le le régime
métropolitain parce qu'encore une fois
il n'y a pas une une vocation nécessaire
une spécificité qui plaide pour que on
est une différence entre et j'en parle
devant Vivianne Maly parce que c'est un
sujet qu'elle porte aussi avec force et
conviction de de différence convaincu
que on doit avoir une approche commune
en revanche en revanche et c'est là où
où nous appelons et nous plaidons pour
une différenciation pour une
territorialisation il est des sujets qui
ne se retrouvent pas ici en métropole
entre un territoire littoral ou un
territoire de montagne comme des sujets
qui peuvent être très différents selon
le bassin selon la particularité du
territoire dans lequel on se trouve que
l'on soit en Guyane à Mayotte ou ou ou
en Polynésie et puis renforcer l'encore
le président du Sénat lad ce couple
maire préfet ou maire haut commissaire
convaincu
qu'aujourd'hui pour répondre à ces
injonctions de l'État vous avez besoin
de souplesse et d'agilité et làdessus
c'est vraiment un point sur lequel nous
voulons pousser l'avantage au Sénat
parce que trop souvent quand on se
déplace sur vos territoires on entend ce
phénomène parfois de de lassitude d'une
réponse beaucoup trop longue d'un état
central qui peinene à comprendre
l'impérieuse nécessité aller vite pour
vous parce que vite pour vous c'est
surtout mieux répondre et répondre en
temps et en heure aux exigences et aux
aspirations de vos concitoyens et cela
pour nous fait sens et ce que nous
voulons c'est là aussi revisiter quelque
part ce fameux article 72 de de de de la
Constitution pardon excusez-moi ainsi
que le fait de
repenser l'intervention du préfet ou du
Haut Commissaire pour justement avoir
cette cette plus grande agilité pour
nous c'est un des points centrals de ce
rapport parce que voyez-vous nous vivons
quelque chose de singulier jamais dans
la 5e République nous n'avons eu et
c'est vrai sur l'ensemble des
territoires de France autant de
démissions de M nous arrivons à plus de
30000 démissions d'élus locaux depuis
2020 depuis le début de ce mandat et
nous ne pouvons pas rester les bras
Ballans et parmi parmi les explications
à cette démotivation il y a ce sentiment
parfois d'être incompris parfois d'être
même déclassé selon le territoire dans
lequel on est considérant que l'État
veut encore une fois calquer en tout
point et en tout lieu du territoire un
modèle qui est pensé à Paris et ne voyez
pas Malis dans mon propos ou une façon
de de présenter les choses de façon
caricaturale mais trop souvent parce
qu'on ne comprend pas ce qui se joue sur
nos territoires et là-dessus c'est
vraiment un sujet qui nous tient à cœur
c'est redonner l'agilité nécessaire en
redonnant du souffle à ce couple maire
préfet ou maire au commissaire pour que
vous puissiez avoir des réponses qui
soit beaucoup plus instantané à à vos
problématiques cela bien sûr nous invite
à réfléchir autant sur le volet
constitutionnel que sur le le volet
organique c'est ce que nous prons nous
proposons de faire avec ce rapport mais
je me permettrai de de citer le le
groupe de travail présidé par le
président du Sénat sur la
décentralisation et la déconcentration
parce qu'il n'y aura pas de de Bonn
décentralisation s'il n'y a pas une
réelle déconcentration et ça me permet
de de rendre hommage au travail qui a
été fait par par Stéphane artanau et qui
a trouvé justement sa place dans le
groupe de travail sur sur la
décentralisation enfin dernier point
parce que je ne veux pas être trop long
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de sujets que
je n'aborderai pas dans le détail
aujourd'hui mais que vous retrouverez
facilement sur le site du Sénat avec la
présentation détaillée du rapport c'est
le statut de l'élu je préfère le terme
condition d'exercice du Monda local mais
j'insiste sur ce point pourquoi
j'insiste parce qu'on on voit aussi une
forme de de lassitude il y a 20 ans et
pour avoir replongé mon nez dans
certains rapport du Sénat finalement il
y a 20 ans on se posait la même question
et avec Françoise Gattel nous avons
beaucoup travaillé sur ce sujet pour
savoir quel était finalement
le le point principal qui invitait les
maires ou les élus à à se dire à mi
mandat je ne referai plus finalement un
un nouveau mandat parce que je considère
que le temps est venu de passer la main
aujourd'hui ce qui est beaucoup plus
inquiétant c'est que les nouveaux
entrants dans la vie municipale
comprendre les femmes et les hommes qui
commen leur premier mandat nous disent
avec la même lassitude je ne referai pas
de nouveaux mandats pour l'ensemble des
raisons que j'aiévoquer la difficulté à
agir la difficulté pour l'élu d'être
finalement cet acteur qui a en main son
destin considérant par la même qu'il
puisse répondre aux aspirations de ces
ces concitoyennes et et de de ses
concitoyens et ça je crois que c'est
vraiment quelque chose à prendre en
compte alors on a essayé de le faire sur
l'ensemble des aspects à commencé par la
question de la formation aux élus en en
essayant de revisiter un petit peu le le
sujet puisque nous étions passés de
quelque chose qui était peut-être un
petit peu trop large à quelque chose de
trop encadré convaincu aussi que les
femmes et les hommes qui intègre la vie
municipale qui finalement ont à cœur de
faire faire bouger la vie de de de leur
commune ont parfois du mal à se
familiariser avec
l'immensité des normes des sigles et de
tout ce qui finalement nécessite d'être
pris en compte si on veut comprendre le
fonctionnement et la bonne marche de la
commune le deuxème sujet le président y
a répondu c'est la question des
violences aux élus et de la difficulté
aujourd'hui à mener à bien son mandat
lorsqueon l'on a face à soi avec
insistance les réseaux sociaux qui
aujourd'hui permettent à chacune et à
chacun de nos concitoyens en temps réel
et parfois ex abrupto de venir commenter
la vie publique de façon assez violente
ou alors tout simplement sont confrontés
à une violence verbale ou physique nous
avons déposé un texte qui a été voté ici
même au Sénat qui permet de renforcer
l'échelle des peines en les calant sur
l'ensemble des personnes qui sont les
forces de sécurité et les personnes qui
sont dépositaires de de l'autorité
publique ou euh en renforçant la
protection fonctionnelle et
juridictionnelle sur laquelle nous
avions déjà travaillé ici même sur le
texte engagement et proximité au Sénat
mais nous souhaitons aller beaucoup plus
loin parce que nous voulons protéger de
toutes les manières possibles les élus
les femmes et les hommes qui s'engagent
au au service de leurs concitoyens et
que vous représentez aujourd'hui dans
cette dans cette salle c'est aussi la
question tout simplement des indemnités
parce que nous croyons qu'à un moment
donné la démocratie locale elle a un
coup tout simplement dans la capacité
qu'elle offre pour celles et ceux qui
laissent de côté leur activité
professionnelle parce qu'aujourd'hui on
l'a vu on a essayé de le mesurer être
élu local c'est beaucoup plus
chronophage que cela ne l'était il y a
il y a 10 ou 20 ans et qu'il faut aussi
pouvoir se consacrer à son mandat et
dire les choses très clairement et je
sais que il y a cher Françoise Gatel un
travail qui est mené par la Délégation
aux collectivités parce qu'au Sénat on
aime bien dire les choses mais surtout
on aime bien avoir une copie qui est
clair qui ne souffre pas de contestation
et quand on dit les choses on aime bien
qu'ell soi exprimée clairement donc je
sais que la délégation fait un gros
travail sur sur ce sujet et puis
d'autres d'autres points que vous
retrouverez dans le rapport qui ont par
exemple voocation comme on a pu le faire
avec les sapeurs pompiers à faire en
sorte que vos années de mandat d'élu
puissent être pris en compte dans le
calcul de de vos retraites autant de de
sujets qui ont animé notre réflexion et
qui permettent aujourd'hui de présenter
un panel de propositions très claires
très concrètes qui ont vocation à
faciliter la vie votre quotidien et la
vie que vous menez chaque jour pour
servir l'ensemble de de celles et ceux
qui résident dans dans vos communes
voilà en quelques mots ce que je
souhaitais dire bien sûr nous sommes à
votre disposition pour répondre à à à
toutes vos questions je veux fer bien
les propos qui ont été tenus par le
président Larcher à l'instant président
du Sénat je crois que plus que jamais
nous avons à cœur et parfois même nous
les prenons en modèle nos 212 communes
ultramarine c'est pour nous quelque
chose d'essentiel tout simplement parce
qu'elle nous renforce dans l'idée que la
commune c'est quelque chose de différent
c'est un échelon différent c'est une
strate qui est différente et qui mérite
qu'on y prête une attention toute
particulière dans un pays qui est
souvent aujourd'hui quel que soit le
territoire dans lequel on se trouve
malmené dans lequel nos concitoyens ont
besoin de réponse et vous avez montré
vous avez toujours témoigné de
l'attention permanente que vous portez
finalement à l'épanouissement de nos
concitoyens et vous êtes finalement ce
ce rempart contre les crises à chaque
fois qu'il y a une crise dans notre pays
les femmes et les hommes élus se
retrouvve en première ligne et je crois
que l'institution aujourd'hui que nous
représentons le le Sénat se doit aussi
de montrer combien elle est attentive à
votre quotidien combien elle aspire
finalement à sanctuariser cette cet
esprit communal qui est particulièrement
important essentiel dans la période dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons merci en
tout cas de de votre attention et puis
tout à fait disposé à répondre à vos
interrogations sur ce sujet merci merci
infiniment monsieur le sénateur Mathieu
Darnaud vous avez démontré annoncé en
tout cas on a bien compris votre ardeur
et votre passion à défendre les élus et
la commune à travers ce rapport que je
vous rappelle le titre avis de tempête
sur la démocratie locale soignons le mal
des Maes c'était le titre de ce rapport
et vous allez pouvoir poser des
questions dans un instant je vais passer
la parole à la sénatrice Catherine
concon qui va nous faire un témoignage
de terrain avec sa triple casquette si
je puis dire madame la sénatrice c'est à
VOUS bonjour à toutes et à tous
rassurez-vous la casquette que je
préfère c'est celle d'être avant tout
une
martiniquaise impliquée citoyenne et qui
ne rechignera jamais à la tâche comme
mes compatriotes monsieur sollicite de
par le territoire je tiens à saluer
singulièrement monsieur le Président du
Sénat cher Gérard lché j'ai l'occasion
déjà de vous le dire plusieurs fois mais
j'apprécie beaucoup votre ouverture
d'esprit et cette place que vous donnez
à nos pays régulièrement dans les
réflexions et dans les débats qui ont
cours au Sénat nos pays ne sont pas la
petite cerise sur le gâteau pour vous
nous sommes ingrédient à part entière de
ce gâteau républicain institutionnel et
vous nous le témoignez régulièrement je
salue également tous les collègues
parlementaires j'ai eu aperçu des
députés bien sû les sénateurs qui sont
là très nombreux y compris à côté de moi
madame la présidente de la délégation
outreem fraîchement élu avec bonheur
cher Micheline jacqu qui vient de si
beau pays Saint-Bart et puis une
attention aussi pour tous ceux qui sont
là je vais les saluer singulièrement
parce que je crois en cette humanité
très particulière très singulière qu'il
y a derrière chacun de nos pays donc je
salue les
Guadeloupéens je salue les
Calédoniens je salue les
Guyanais je salue les
maoraais je salue les maoraais je l'ai
dit je salue Saint-Pierre et miclon les
Saint-Pierrois c'est bien ça
saint-pierret pardon excuse-moi les
Saint-Pierrois je salue bien sûr les
Polynésiens je crois que j'ai fait le
tour de la planète et les walisiens
voilà et les walisiens
voilà et bien sûr je gardais le plus
beau pour la fin les
réunionnaires voilà pour moi il est
important que derrière tous ces
territoires on puissent singulariser des
peuples qui ont souvent des histoires
différentes des passés différents mais
qui représentent à eux tout seul une une
une une particularité bien sûr une
affection très très particulière pour
mon pays la Martinique et tous les
martiniquenss qui sont présents j'en ai
vu là de toutes les communes ch cher gr
le carbé avec mon ami
jean-claudecville j'ai vu le diamant
j'ai aperçu tris h j'ai aperçu le
lamantin j'ai aperçu Riviè pilote non
franchement vous êtes les bienvenus ici
sachez que le Sénat c'est la maison
commune c'est la maison de la République
et tant qu'on aura un présid président
comme celui que nous avons elle sera
aussi votre maison je sais pas ce qui
nous attend demain Président vous savez
la la politique est souvent un grand
carrefour d'inconnu et on ne sait jamais
ce qui nous attend demain et comment
pourrait pourrait demain tourner les
qualités de la République liberté
égalité fraternité ces trois mots
auxquels rajoutait volontiers mes céser
identité et c'est cette identité que
j'ai tenu à saluer dans le ouverture de
mon propos nous avons ici en particulier
des élus municipaux et même quand on a
été sénateur comme moi ça a été le cas
on a aussi un passé d'élu communal parce
que c'est très rare que quelqu'un qui ne
soit pas passé par ce temple de
l'exercice démocratique ce temple
républicain qui est la commune devienne
sénateur c'est un exercice incroyable et
extraordinaire de bonheur en tout cas
j'y a j'ai pratiqué cette fonction
pendant 17 ans était en mer adjoint de
la plus grosse ville de Martinique et je
peux vous dire ça était pour moi 17 ans
de bonheur et ça étit mon plus beau
moment d'élu mon plus beau moment d'élu
parce que on est au carrefour des
besoins et des sollicitations de
l'humain on s'occupe de lui de la
naissance à la mort on s'occupe de lui à
tous les moments les les heureux comme
les malheureux et on s'occupe également
de territoire que l'on souhaite Heux
en tentant de l'aménager au mieux de lui
porter de la prospérité de la valeur
ajoutée et c'est un énorme chantier
alors c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui euh la
fonction municipale est extrêmement
secouée ça a d'abord commencé avec cet
étage de la fusée qui a été rajouté euh
que sont les
EPCI les communautés de communes les
communautés d'aglo ou alors les
métropoles dans un certain nombre de
grands de grands centres comme en France
métropolitaine aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'entre vous ma et lu municipal doivent
se sentir très dépossédés et très
éloignés de la réalité que leur
assigne leurs compatriotes leurs
citoyens aujourd'hui une compétence
comme celle des déchets est généralement
dévolue à la communauté de commune mais
dès qu'il y a le moindre papier gras sur
vos trottoir et bien c'est meilleur
qu'on en vu et pourtant le maire n'a pas
toujours les manettes puisque ces
budgets qui sont maintenant confondus
dans un gros pot sont à partager y
compris en matière de responsabilité
avec bien d'autres le maire subit aussi
une crise le maire et bien sûr sa
collectivité une crise existentielle
quelle est désormais son rôle au milieu
de cet amaigrissement progressif cet
amaigrissement progressif de ses
compétences de ses pouvoir quel est son
rôle et pourtant la pression est encore
énorme il y a une crise d'autorité le
maire n'est plus le personnage sacralisé
comme l' était comme il était dans la
commune à l'époque missel li comme on
dit en créole de chez nous c'était un
personnage qu'on respectait aujourd'hui
il est plus àorté de gifle et
régulièrement on lui dit pas trop mi
mais on lui fait beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de reproches souvent de manière
très violente au travers d'un exercice
qui est très aimé par les médias et que
personnellement je déteste les fameux
coup de gueule que vous devez savoir qui
sont lâchés comme ça sur les ondes sans
modération sans réglage sans rien du
tout on peut tout dire et le contraire
de tout y compris au milieu de 1000
mensonges et derrière il est très
difficile de rectifier une
contreevérité le maire est confronté
aussi à cette vitesse
qui est qui qui fait notre quotidien
Aujourd'hui celle qui nous est assignée
par les réseaux sociaux une crise de
l'immédiaté tout doit être fait vite et
rapidement ce qu'on pouvait attendre un
an maintenant et ben onattend plus un
jour c'est là même tout de suite c'est
maintenant et même quand on a déposé un
dossier si une semaine après le boulon
n'est pas fait et ben le ma n'est pas
bon le ma est trop
lent on a bien sûr une crise de moyens
qu'on ne peut pas qu'on ne peut pas nier
une crise de moyens et ces moyens ne
sont pas que financiers j'ai l'habitude
de dire que c'est peut-être le niveau
financier qui est peut-être le plus
facile à régler avec quelques combats
avec nos présidents de commission de
finances respectif quelques bon lobbying
au niveau de l'État on peut attraper un
petit mon par-ci un petit Milon PAR-L
mais je parle surtout en particulier de
moyens quand je pense par exemple à
l'invasion de sargas dans un certain
nombre de nos communes euh je pense à la
Martinique à la Guadeloupe à l'archipel
de Guadeloupe on a une représentante ici
de des ceintes et bien on a on est face
à une réalité difficile qui même lorsque
des budgets sont donnés une fois qu'on a
ramassé ces sgas on en fait croire
surtout quand on vient nous dire
qu'elles sont extrêmement toxique et
extrêmement pollué par toute espèce de
de produit y compris pour la Guadeloupe
et la Martinique de chordécone on a
aussi un combat à mener au quotidien
contre l'administration
française chaque délibération scruté
chaque virgule on a parlé tout à l'heure
de la CdP NAF mais pas que la loi sur
l'eau le moins de petit pont il faut
mettre un petit trou parce que il faut
une loi sur l'eau qui dure une mission
loi sur l'eau qui dure 1 an avec une
lecture parfois de l'ADAL qui vient vous
dire oh non il y a un petit poisson très
rare qui et si vous mettez un petit
mètre cube de béton il va disparaîre de
la planète pendant ce temps le pont est
en train de s'effondrer vos habitants ne
peuvent plus passer il y a a cette cet
allègement de la de de l'administration
dans des pays qui sont soumis à
énormément de risqu en dehors du risque
avalanche nous sommes soumis à tous les
risques on a les volcans la terre
tremble on a des risques inondation on a
des risques rraite côte et cetera et
face à nous une administration qui nous
dit tout le temps c'est pas possible
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible et
puis j'ai parlé déjà des des EPCI et
puis une un problème de compétence qui
est souvent par alors Mathieu il me
semble que c'est Mathieu ou je sais qui
a ou le président d'ailleurs qui a parlé
de la fameuse clause de compétence
générale oui faut que ce soit sacralisé
à aucun moment un ma ne devrait être
empêché lorsqu'il s'agit de faire du
bien à sa population il y a un risque
qui est là il y a une difficulté qui est
là il faut que le ma puisse réagir bien
sûr en tenant compte du cadre légal mais
qu'on ne lui assigne pas en permanence
un empilement de de de procédure et bien
qui mettent souvent en péril la vie de
ses administrés et la vie de son
territoire alors sachez qu'ici au Sénat
euh vous êtes très très bien
représenté on a des combattants on a des
combattants de la Première heur qui
siège au Sénat et qui ne laisse rien
passer peut vous le dire ils sont combat
ils travaillent énormément conc la
légende le Sénat c'est pas la chambre où
on gonfle j'aimerais bien de temps en
temps président que vous nous accordier
2h dans le planning qu'on puisse se
poser un peu moi je suis arrivé ce matin
je suis déjà au travail on y sera encore
la nuit c'est c'est une chambre où on
travaille énormément composé de beaucoup
d'anciens maires d'anciens ministres
avec une exigence très très haute et qui
sort des combats coqu qu'on qu'on
aperçoit de l'autre côté du côté des
Invalides euh parce que bon ici lorsque
la loi arrive souvent en 2e rang et bien
on a le temps de voir venir les carences
on a le temps de de venir voir le
désordre et pendant que ça s'étripe
ailleurs et ben nous on est au travail
les commissions se réunissent il y a
énormément d'auditions et lorsque le
Sénat livre en travail je peux vous dire
que c'est un travail aboutit rigoureux
et fini on est très très loin de la
légende à laquelle on pourrait croire je
vais prendre le même temps que Mathieu
histoire histoire de
parité histoire de
Pasut chose que je l'autre chose que je
c'est c'était pour tainer ma l'autre
chose que je voulais vous dire c'est que
euh et et je vais conclure dessus plus
que jamais nos pays doivent être au
combat et c'est ce que nous avons
compris au Sénat il n'est plus le temps
où nous étions là en train d'attendre
que dispositif nous tombe sur la tête et
puis on commence à réagir on n'est pas
d'accord on va manifester dans la rue on
fait des pétitions ce temps-là est
terminé il faut absolument que nous
soyons en amont en veille de tout ce qui
pourrait nous arriver et c'est le cas en
ce moment du débat sur l'ctoin de mer il
n'est pas question pour nous de nous
renfermer et puis de dire touche pas
touche pas à l' toi de M on en a besoin
certes c'est une taxe qui est utile à
nos finances mais il faut aussi qu'on se
pose la question de sa pertinence moi
j'ai un avis dessus on pourra en
débattre mais moi c'est une taxe que qui
me pose beaucoup de problèmes y compris
d'éthique et de philosophie par rapport
à des situations d'inéquité d'injustice
que je ressens et on pourrait en
discuter longtemps il est temps que nous
soyons en amont que nous ayons en
permanence le le stylo de notre destin
en main et que lorsqu'on entend dire
qu'il y aura une réforme dans l'air et
bien que dans les 3 qu mois qui suivent
nous soyons tous en mesure de dire voilà
ce que nous voulons voilà ce que nous
voulons c'est cette cette ce réflexe
qu'il faut qu'on ait ça passe par
beaucoup de formations qu'il faudrait
qu'on accepte parce que être élu
municipal du jour au lendemain ne fait
pas de nous un expert de la loi un
expert du règlement et un expert de de
de des des des différents tuyaux
complexes et compliqués de la République
il faut absolument miser pour que nos
élus soit en situation de leadership
permanent soit puissant et que l'on
puisse à tout moment pouvoir dire voilà
ce que nous voulons le temps de voilà ce
que N nous ne voulons pas est terminé il
faut inverser la termin ie et faire de
nous des acteurs des figures de prou des
gens qui sont en alternativ qui
précèdent les difficultés et qui soit en
permanence en mesure de d'être face- à
face avec la République non pas dans une
relation père enfant ça a longtemps
existé les enfants c'étaient nous le
père c'était l'ancien colon et bien il
faut que les choses s'inversent et que
nous soyons plus que jamais dans une
situation mature d'adulte à adulte se
regardant sans complexe sans dénis les
yeux dieux dans les yeux pour avancer
pour le bienêre de nos populations parce
que comme disait un grand martiniquet
les meilleurs experts de nous-mêmes et
ben c'est nous-mêmes avant tout merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup madame la
sénatrice pour
cette cette défense également avec
hardardeur et passion j'en avais parlé
avec le le le sénateur à côté de vous
mais c'était sans c'était vous oublierz
hein avec votre vitamine venant du
volcan de la Martinique merci encore
pour cette défense des élus ils vont
pouvoir vous répondre elles et ils vont
pouvoir vous répondre dans un instant et
je cède la parole à madame le sénateur
d'il Villen Madame Françoise Gatel qui
travaille avec sa délégation également
sur les outresemires et récemment elle a
travaillé sur l'intercommunalité en
Polynésie c'est à vous madame le
sénateur merci beaucoup monsieur le le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs chers collègues députés
représentants des associations d'élu et
notamment de la MF et vous tous qui V z
des outremèes pour nous parler de ce que
vous êtes de ce que vous voulez faire de
vos ambitions et de ce que vous attendez
de nous alors moi je ne suis pas
d'outreemè je suis de la Bretagne ce Far
West mais je vous rassure dans cette
terre de Bretagne il y a des gens qui
ont aussi beaucoup de caractère et de
détermination et je suis heureuse de la
partager de les partager avec mes
collègues alors peut-être en complément
vous avez vu qu'ici les gens ont du
caractère de la conviction et de la
détermination nous ne lâchons rien comme
on le dit souvent et le président
l'arché est un excellent chef
d'orchestre d'une sorte de de tribu de
gens qui défendent avec
conviction le bloc local et notamment la
commune pourquoi parce que l'on dit
souvent que la commune c'est le dernier
kilomètre je pense que c'est le premier
kilomè parce que c'est celui de la
proximité c'est celui où chaque jour ce
conj jugue les valeurs de notre
République que la liberté l'égalité la
fraternité et que la cohésion sociale
dont nous avons tant besoin c'est autour
du maire que ça se fabrique et je vous
invite à lire l'excellente édito ce
matin dans Le Figaro où on parle des
maires comme des gardiens du temple et
ce sont les gardiens du temple de la
République et de la solidarité alors et
vous allez voir qu'au Sénat alors on a
de la voix on a de la conviction et que
nous sommes tous différents mais que
nous partageons le même discours et la
même action parce que vous verrez que
les propos de nous trois et de cher
Micheline dont je salue la récente
élection et brillante à la présidence
nous disons les mêmes choses parfois
avec nos mots et nos accents mais c'est
exactement la même chose et très
concrètement je voudrais rappeler les
très récents travaux du Sénat et ceux
que nous avons entamés le premier c'est
Mathieu d'Arnaud qui en a parlé c'est la
protection des élus il n'est pas
acceptable dans une république et dans
une démocratie que ceux qui s'engagent
librement comme des citoyens
responsables pour aller porter l'intérêt
général servir leurs concitoyens soit
les victimes d'agression ou d'un bashing
d'élus que l'on connaît donc nous avons
voté ici à la quasi unanimité une
proposition de loi sénatoriale sur la
protection des élus et au-delà de ce que
Mathieu Darnaud a expliqué comme itemme
il y a quelque chose de très important
pour lesquels les mares doivent se
battre et doivent être extrêmement
vigilants c'est le lien renforcé entre
l'univers de la justice et les élus
locaux car il n'est pas normal qu'un élu
local un maire ne sache pas ce qu'il
advient des plaintes qui qui ont été
déposées que parfois elles n'était pas
jusqu'ici prise en compte et qu'il ne
sache pas ce qu'il a devient sur son
territoire de quelqu'un qui n'est pas un
élu mais un citoyen qui pour une raison
ou une autre a été lo du territoire et
soudainement un habitant vient vous voir
en disant Monsieur le Maire je comprends
rien un tel qui avait été éloigné du
territoire il est de retour et le maire
ne le savait pas donc il faut vraiment
faire cette chaîne de de sécurité pour
que le maire puisse exercer son vraiment
le deuxième point c'est ce qu'on appelle
un statut de l'élu alors le mot statut
est gênant parce que dans les maires il
y a des retraités il y a des salariés de
l'état des salariés de grandes ou
petites entreprises mais en tout cas ce
que l'on sait c'est que chaque citoyen
dans notre pays doit être à même de
pouvoir s'engager s'il a envie de
s'engager pour servir ses concitoyens
mais que si le mandat d'élu est un
engagement civique et ça n'est pas un
métier il n'est plus normal que les élus
locaux soient victimes et subissent des
conséquences financières négatives alors
même qu'ils sont engagés pour servir
donc nous nous venons de rendre jeudi
huit
propositions au nom de la délégation
mais je sais que le Sénat va approuve ça
huit propositions pour permettre que si
vous vous engagez vous devz avoir une
indemnité qui vous permet de ne pas
perdre par rapport à votre situation
professionnelle antérieure donc il y a
huit propositions très précis je ne vais
pas les détailler mais elles font déjà
les bonnes pages des des jour nos
professionnels et nous travaillerons de
la même manière sur la retraite et un
certain nombre de choses donc une
indemnité qui doit être à la hauteur et
que l'État doit assumer pour une partie
parce que quand vous exercez votre
mandat de maire l'état civil
l'organisation des élections l'urbanisme
ce sont des tâches de l'État et que si
on remplaçait l'ensemble des des élus
exécutifs c'est-à-dire les maires et les
adjoints par des fonctionnaire le coût
pour l'État serait d'une autre nature et
la qualité de l'engagement ne serait pas
le même et puis nous
entamons deux autres volets de ce statut
de l'élu le second ce sera donc
faciliter l'engagement et faciliter
l'exercice du mandat c'est-à-dire que il
doit être plus facile d'avoir des
autorisations d'absence de se déplacer
il doit être plus facile de faire garder
ses enfants et quand on est étudiant on
peut aussi avoir envie de devenir élu
local donc faciliter
l'engagement faciliter j'en dirais un
mot tout à l'heure l'exercice du du
mandat c'est on devrait pouvoir être
maire sans avoir besoin à longueur de
journée de paracétamool parce que les
services de l'État vous donnent la
migrainee non mais moi j'étais maire
j'étais maire et j'ai vécu ça je suis
rentrée dans un bureau toute seule il y
avait neu personnes je me suis dit mon
affaire doit être importante et on me
dit Madame le Maire alors votre idée
elle est excellente mais ça ne va pas
être possible et ben si il faut trouver
des solutions et j'en dirai un mot tout
à l'heure et ensuite il y a un troisième
volet qui est très important c'est
comment on encourage les gens à
s'engager sur un mandat de maire parce
que leur sortie sera sécurisée vous
connaissez comme moi des élus qui ont
pris des engagements en terme de
diminution de temps de travail qui ont
parfois je veux dire vécu des vies
personnel difficile à cause de leur
engagement et un dimanche soir parce que
les élections municipales c'est toujours
un dimanche soit parce que vous avez
décidé de vous arrêter le lundi matin
votre agenda évide mais vous en
connaissez comme moi qui le dimanche
soir ont été avec surprise balayé il se
retrouve le lundi en difficulté pour
retrouver un emploi et se réinsérer il
faut donc qu'on traite ce volet là le
deuxième point alors je salue tout
particulièrement tu ne m'en voudas pas
parce que toi tuas fait tu as fait le
tour des outremèes je voudrais saluer un
salut particulier pour la Polynésie
parce que à la demande du président du
Sénat et notre collègue Lana Toni nous
avons fait il y a quelques mois une
mission en Polynésie sur
l'intercommunalité et nous avons si nous
ne le savions pas découvert ce qu'est
l'éloignement par rapport à la métropole
ce qu'est l'insularité et la
particularité de différence que vous
avez y compris au sein des autres y
compris au sein de la Polynésie que
l'égalité de droit se reconnaît par la
différence des moyens et je pense et le
président Larcher porte ça avec beaucoup
de conviction qu'il faut que l'État nous
écoute et que l'État aurait moins
d'ennui s'il écoutait s'il nous
permettait d'agir parce que je pense que
les élus locaux dès lors qu'on leur
laisse de la liberté ils savent faire
parce qu'ils sont aussi responsables
donc il est très important tant qu'on
permette de trouver des solutions qui
vous qui vous vont le mieux possible et
au sein des outremèes cela a été rappelé
vous avez aussi votre champ de
différence et nous nous défendons l'idée
nous étions tout à l'heure en réunion
avec nos amis de des marquise nous
défendons l'idée qu'il faut avancer en
permettant en tout cas d'expérimenter ce
que peut-être je prends cet exemple des
Marquises mais vous en avez plein anop
d'archipel où l'on va de don des
capacités à agir en matière économique
ou touristique je reprends cet exemple
bientôt au marquise il y aura un site
patrimonial de
l'UNESCO et donc il faut que ce
territoire a des capacités à agir en
matière de tourisme et d'économie et
puis dernier point sur ce sujet de
l'adaptation c'est la déconcentration
des services de l'État alors je suis
heureuse de saluer notre collègue Agnès
caniller qui est en face de moi qui avec
Eric kerouche il y a quelques mois on
fait un rapport que tous les ministres
devraient lire matin midi et
soir parce que tout est dedans
c'està-dire on sait bien que tous les
diagnostics ont été fait c'està-dire
l'État ne doit plus être celui qui
contrôle quand vous avez déjà fait les
choses ou celui qui vous donne des
injonctions depuis Paris que vous
habitiez en Martinique ou que vous soyez
élu dans ma
Bretagne la déconcentration c'est un
état avec un préfet ou un haut
commissaire qui au côté des élus pour
trouver des solutions et non pas pour
arriver comme tout est fait vous dire ça
va pas être possible contrôle de
l'égalité a dit non vous recommenencez
tout donc il faut que l'État soit au
côté des des élus et puis la
simplification alors moi je ne sais même
plus prononcer ce motl parce
qu'apparemment on a du mal à se faire
comprendre n'est-ce pas président les
choses devraient être simples il y a ici
au Sénat dans l'hémicycle un éminent
personnage qui s'appelle Portalis ou qui
s'appelait portalise il disait les lois
sont faites pour les hommes enfin les
femmes aussi mais à l'époque il disait
pas et non pas les hommes pour les lois
c'estàdire la loi elle doit servir elle
doit être simple et elle doit être
visible donc nous nous avons proposé
suite au rapport que nous avons fait sur
l'intercommunalité dans les Marquises
qu'il y ait et c'est une proposition de
loi de notre collègue Lana toon la mise
en ligne par l'état d'une version l'idée
à jour de toutes les dispositions
législatives que vous devriez savoir par
cœur mais qui sont éparpillé dans des
tas de codes et donc pour appliquer la
loi il faut que celle-ci soit simple et
qu'on la connaisse donc voilà une
proposition concrète que nous
soutiendrons de toutes nos forces et
puis enfin le mot de la fin c'est celui
de subsidiarité alors ça paraît aussi
compliqué que simplification la
subsidiarité c'est très simple c'est
laisser faire le bon niveau et le bon
niveau on sait bien que c'est souvent
celui des élus locaux et je n'ose
imaginer je terminerai par ça une petite
anecdote en janvier dernier je vais
comme beaucoup d'entre vous à une
cérémonie des vœux j'arrive dans dans
cette dans cette petite commune et puis
il y avait trois dames qui arrêtai pas
de râer sur leur mer mais d'une manière
qui n'était pas sympa j'ai trouvé ça
moche parce que c'était la première
cérémonie de vœux de ce nouveau maire
élu en 2020 parce qu'à cause du virus
covid il a pas pu faire de cérémonie de
vœux et à un moment le maire me donne la
parole et j'ai dit mais ce que je crois
de tout mon cœur et que tout le monde
croit ici et que le président du Sénat
défend j'ai juste dit votre mère il
prend soin de vous tous les jours alors
vous pouvez ne pas avoir voté pour lui
vous vous pouvez trouver qu'il est mal
habillé que vraiment il est pas possible
voilà vous pouvez avoir un avis
différent mais respectez-le parce qu'il
prend soin de vous et si on ne prend pas
soin de nos élus locaux un jour personne
ne prendra soin de vous donc voilà ce
qu'ici au Sénat nous portons tous
ensemble avec détermination et nous
sommes sûrs de votre soutien et votre
surveillance positive au cas où nous
aurions un moment de faiblesse mais ça
ne peut pas arriver parce que le
président veille au grain je remercie
merci beaucoup madame le sénateur
Françoise
gel merp coup en tout cas encore une
fois une défense des élus du terrain
vous l'avez compris tous les sénateurs
ici présents sénateurs et sénatrices
bien évidemment défendre votre statut
place maintenant aux questions pour des
raisons d'organisation je vais commencer
à demander au président d'association
des maires s'il veulent bien nous faire
un partage de d'expérience ou une
question que vous voudriez bien partager
oui non sinon je vais faire un choix
démocratique donc je vais décider toute
seule s'il n'y a pas de mains levée et
ensuite les élus et les sénateurs est-ce
qu'il y a un président d'association des
maires ou une présidente qui voudrait
prendre la parole ok non sinon je
demande si ou ça ah bien évidemment
madame Sonia Lagarde présidente de
l'Association des mes de
Nouvelle-Calédonie je vais demander un
micro évidemment si quelqu'un ne l'a pas
qu'on la porte oui vous l'avez voilà ça
arrive merci de lui faire un accueil
s'il vous plaît le temps que le micro
arrive voilà merci
beaucoup bien merci
merci beaucoup j'été ravi d'entendre un
certain nombre de messages venant des
sénateurs et qui parler des
particularités de
l'autreem et surtout des différences qui
existent en outrem entre les
départements et les
territoires ce matin j'ai eu
l'impression que on faisait un peu
l'amalgame
entre les départements alors que nous
sommes si
différent
alors moi je suis en
Nouvelle-Calédonie je sais que le sujet
va arriver très
bientôt que les discussions sont
engagées qu'elles
sont compliquées le chemin sera long et
difficile mais ce que je voulais dire
ici puisque vous adressez au maire et
vous avez parlé effectivement tous d'une
même voix concernant ces maères qui
s'occupent qui sont des acteurs de
proximité qui sont proches de leurs
administrés alors à l'AUE de ces
discussions qui s'ouvrent moi je
voudrais simplement vous interpeller
c'est qu'il ne faut pas oublier les
maères dans ces
discussions j'insiste parce que
aujourd'hui il y a une confiscation des
discussions par un certain nombre d'élus
locaux et les maires qui sont on le dit
tous les jours des acteurs de proximité
et bien ils sont à nouveau les oubliés
de l'histoire et Dieu sait s'il y a a
des choses à changer pour les communes
le code des communes de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie n'est pas le même que
métropole sur les compétences qui sont
celles des communes aujourd'hui et bien
sur le développement de nos territoires
sur leurbanisme il va falloir changer
les choses pour donner excusez-moi un
peu plus de pouvoir au Mair qui
aujourd'hui sont extrêmement dépendant
des règles d'urbanisme des principes
directeurs qui sont votés par la
Nouvelle-Calédonie et en plus il y a
aussi un code de l'urbanisme avec les
provinces c'est toute la
complexité de ces compétences en
Nouvelle-Calédonie qui sont un véritable
millefeuilles et où plus personne ne
s'y'y reconnaît et où les maires dans
l'aménagement de leur territoire et bien
sont suspendus à la fois à des règles
d'urbanisme de la Nouvelle-Calédonie les
principes directeur c'est normal mais
que les provinces c'est un code de
l'urbanisme qui s'impose à vous et que
quand vous avez un PUD il faut le voter
exactement de la même manière qu'à la
province il faut être bien avec le
président de la province ou la
présidente de la province pour que votre
PUD soit adopté et donc ça veut dire que
l'aménagement de votre territoire sur
lequel vous avez été élu bien évidemment
vous échappe donc voilà je voulais tout
simplement vous avertir que mais vous le
savez que il ne faudra pas laisser les
maires dans la rédaction d'un futur
statut et j'espère qu'on en aura un et
bien ne pas laisser les maires de côté
et donc si s'il fallait le dire ici au
Sénat puisque de toute façon vous aurez
bien évidemment à à discuter de ce futur
statut et des modifications
institutionnelles qui vont arriver très
bientôt voilà merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup madame la présidente madame
Sonia Lagarde peut-être une réponse du
côté de un avis un mot oui monsieur le
sénateur
oui pour pour dire tout simplement que
je je suis tout à fait d'accord avec les
propos qui viennent d'être tenus par par
Sonia Lagarde la présidente d'ailleurs
je crois qu'on avait eu un échange
il y a quelques temps sur les polices
municipales et et et les problématiques
auxquelles étaient parfois confrontés
les les maires je crois qu' en réalité
quand j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure le
rapport qu'on a commis sur l'avenir de
la commune j'ai pris à dessin le fait
que aujour'hui la commune c'était un
modèle à part finalement dans dans
l'architecture institutionnelle
française à part tout simplement parce
que c'est la collectivité du quotidien
j'ai tendance à dire que c'est un peu la
patrie du quotidien la commune c'est
vraiment ce lieu encore une fois où les
les habitantes nos concitoyens nos
concitoyennes quels qu'ils soit viennent
vous voir pour pour toutes les raisons
et c'est ce qui font que c'est ce qui
fait pardon que nous nous considérons
que la clause de compétence générale
dans la Constitution Catherine le disait
tout à l'heure c'est cette capacité qui
sera laissée au maire de pouvoir évoquer
tous les sujets du quotidien de nos
concitoyens alors bien évidemment que
dans la question du statut et des
discussions institutionnelles qui vont
s'ouvrir la commune doit nécessairement
avoir une place en cela quel est cet
échelon de de base cette capacité aussi
à répondre et à faire en sorte et et on
le voit et et souvent alors Catherine
parlait tout à l'heure des des des
petits poissons dans les rivière on peut
dire exactement la même chose en
métropole avec avec les grenouilles à
ventre jaune et je ne sais quel autre
quelle autre espèce mais la la réalité
c'est que nous avons besoin de cette
l'échelon des communes pour justement
passer les crises passer les difficultés
quotidiennes et faire en sorte qu'il y
ait toujours le fil de la confiance qui
puisse se nouer au à l'échelon de de de
de proximité et parce que je crois que
discuter d'un discuter d'un statut mais
c'est vrai quasiment pour tous les
territoires beaucoup de territoires et
on a vu dans dans le groupe de travail
sur sur la décentralisation la nécessité
qu'il y avait à requestionner l'ensemble
des statuts de l'ensemble de de vos
territoires et bien évid évidemment que
la commune c'est une porte d'entrée je
dirais même que c'est pratiquement la
porte d'entrée sur ces sur ces sujets là
parce qu'encore une fois on part de ce
qui intéresse en premier lieu nos
concitoyennes et nos concitoyens et et
c'est pour ça que je crois qu'il faut
redonner une place centrale à la commune
sur un versant constitutionnel mais
aussi en faisant en sorte que et vous
avez beaucoup parler les uns et les
autres du lien avec l'État qu'on ait le
maximum d'agilité parce que trop souvent
aujourd'hui on est confronté à des
niveaux d'intervention notamment de la
part de l'État qui ralentisent l'action
des mairres et on a parlé du rapport
vous parliez du rapport à la à la
province s'agissant des questions
d'urbanisme mais on pourrait dire
exactement la même chose en métropole ou
dans d'autres territoires et quand on
était avec le le président à point pitre
on l'a évoqué la question du rapport à
l'intercommunalité sur ces sujets donc
il y a un moment donné il faut repartir
de la base c'est-à-dire de la comm
commune qui doit singulièrement sur ces
sujets du quotidien dont l'urbanisme
fait partie avoir les moyens d'action
qui permettent de répondre en temps et
en heure au finalement aux aspirations
des habitants de et des habitants de de
nos communes ça je crois que c'est c'est
vraiment fondamental et malheureusement
là encore le président du Sénat le
disait tout à l'heure on assiste plutôt
à une recentralisation et nous on veut
tordre le coup à ce mouvement qui va
selon nous dans le mauvais sens parce
que plus recentralisera plus on
mettra ce genre de sujet à un niveau
supracommunal plus on éloignera la
décision du concitoyen et le bon
interlocuteur la bonne interlocutrice
c'est le ou la merère je le dis et en
tout cas finalement je me tourne vers
Françoise vers vers Catherine et
Micheline c'est le point commun de
l'ensemble de nos travaux donc bien
évidemment selon moi et pour répondre
très directement et très franchement à
la question la commune doit forcément
avoir son mot à dire sur les évolutions
institutionnell et statutaire merci
infiniment merci beaucoup oui vous
pouvez l'applaudir une autre
intervention dans la salle président
d'association des maires ou Mair oui
monsieur le Président d'association des
maires de Mayotte monsieur Mad madisouf
c'est à vous pour le micro le temps que
le micro arrive vous pouvez l'applaudir
en attendant l'encourager pour son
intervention merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs et sénatrices euh monsieur
madisouf comme ça a été dit euh
président de l'association maire de
maotte et maire de pamanzi
Ben la commune c'est vrai est le
principal personnage qu' l'incarne le
maire évolue dans un contexte difficile
fait de violence ou d'injure ça été dit
contre les élus desmission de ma et
surtout dans
l'Hexagone crise
d'vocation manque de moyens tant humain
que
financier complexité de l'exercice du
mandat concurrence des
inter je partage donc le principe point
évoqué dans ce
rapport notamment celui c'estàdire le
rapport de 12 juillet dernier intitulé
avis de tempête sur la démocratie
locale soignons le mal des
Maes donc euh rendre aux communes la
liberté et leur
avenir
pardon assurer aux commande les moyens
financiers de leur
liberté par contre madame la sénatrice
nous les présidents
[Musique]
de association de automè de la formant
la délégation des autres ma nous savons
ce que nous voulons surtout sur le
trroit de M nous nous sommes concertés
et nous avons décidé que nous ne voulons
pas que cette troit de ma soit
euh comment dirais-je
euh doit évoluer bien sûr mais il il
doit pas disparaître parce que ça c'est
vraiment le lien ou la liberté des
collectivités pour décider de ce que
nous devons avoir pour le développement
de nos communes et j'en passe comme vous
le
savez ça a été dit tout à
l'heure la crise de l'eau qui passe à
maot actuellement est
inédite certes les raisons sont
[Musique]
multiples la rareté de pluies mais aussi
a aussi une négligence aussi vis-à-vis
de l'État concernant tout ce qui est
investissement donc on n'a pas trop
anticipé pour qu'on puisse euh comment
euh ne pas avoir ce cette crise qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui vous le savez aussi
depuis l'année dernière nous
l'association de ma en compagnie de
maires de maotte été reçu ici par
Monsieur le Président Larcher que je
remercie nous avons
soulevé la violence que connaît
Mayotte certes l'état nous a accompagne
nous avons eu une réponse ou des
réponses mais qui n'a pas perduré il
faudrait des réponses qui restent pine à
maotte nous les maires qui sont venus
ici on est au Congrès mais nos pensées
sont à maotte vu de ce qui se passe
là-bas c'est pourquoi je demande à
l'État au Sénat aux élus que vous êtes
de nous accompagner ou de faire pression
à l'état à ce que tout ce qui se passe à
Mayotte cesse parce que nous n'en
pouvons
plus Mayotte n'attire plus des
investisseurs à cause de ces violence
maintenant la crise de l'eau
euh des enfants qui brûlent les voitures
les maisons on on n'est plus un pays ou
une île
attractive donc c'est ce que je voulais
dire au témoigner apportez un peu et que
vous donnez nous vous devez nous nous
apporter votre témoign mais votre
soutien au vu de cette crise qui se
passe à Mayotte merci merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président pour information
nous allons revenir sur la crise de
l'eau dans la deuxème séquence donc si
quelqu'un veut rajouter sur la violence
ou sur une autre thématique madame le
sénateur c'est à vous oui merci merci
beaucoup merci monsieur le Président
peut-être en
écho à à votre propos le mot l'assitude
des mares c'estàd ils n'en veulent plus
comme l'on dit ils sont épuisés par un
un certain nombre de choses les
violences en font partie mais surtout
leur incapacité à agir l'année dernière
le Congrès des mares s'appelait le
pouvoir d'agir c'est-à-dire ce qui est
souhaitable et
nécessaire trop souvent n'est plus
possible parce que soit on n'a pas su
anticiper quand je dis
on je veux dire c'est une responsabilité
un peu collective et qui remonte à
quelques années sans doute quelques
quinquen je pense P que parfois on agit
en
pompier c'est-à-dire on arrive quand il
y a une crise qui est très forte et on
n'arrive pas toujours à éteindre de
manière satisfaisante le feu ou quand on
arrive à éteindre le feu continue à
couver parce que ce que vous dites
monsieur le Président c'est vrai partout
et c'est particulièrement vrai chez vous
c'est que les solutions doivent être
pérennes et elles doivent être travaillé
madame vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
avec les élus locaux et les élus locaux
c'est ceux qui savent et surtout ceux
qui sont comptables devant la population
parce que celui à qui on demande des
comptes c'est le maire et le maire ne
peut pas être le sous-traitant de l'État
chacun l'a dit le maire c'est un
partenaire comme un être vivant qui
marche sur deux jambes et l'État doit
être en accompagnement en stratégie et
en écoutant les élus locaux donc je
crois que ici au Sénat c'est ce que nous
portons et en même temps je pense que on
note parfois quelques progrès et
quelques bons apprentissages en
métropole pendant la crise
covid il y avait presque plus de
règlement figurez-vous parce que il y
avait aucune loi qui n'ait prévu de
gérer la crise covid personne pensait
que çaaré et donc les maires avec les
préfets ils ont inventé des solutions
ils soudainement l'impression que tout
le monde enfin en même temps il était
très stressé mais on respirait parce
qu'il fallait inventer des choses et
qu'à un moment les fonctionnaires de
l'État comme les élus locaux parce que
ils voulaient bien agir ils ont inventé
des solutions et que je pense qu'il faut
redonner cette capacité aux élus locaux
mais ne pas les laisser tout seul et
sincèrement je pense que c'est dans une
relation de confiance et de
responsabilité en identifiant les sujets
je pense qu'à Mayotte les sujets sont
particulièrement identifiés que
aujourd'hui le chemin c'est un chemin
euh qui est long mais on ne doit jamais
faiblir sur le chemin et les élus locaux
que vous êtes portent la responsabilité
la dignité de la République dans les
solutions au
problèmes merci de vos de vos
témoignages merci beaucoup merci
infiniment alors oui il y a une dernière
intervention pour clôturer cette
séquence sur les communes et et ensuite
nous allons passer à la deuxième
séquence puisqu'on court un peu sur le
temps voilà le micro arrive n'hésitez
pas je vous vois pas d'ici à décliner
votre identité s'il vous plaît voilà
merci beaucoup oui bonjour à tous je
suis Madame Carpin Jacqueline
conseillère municipale à la commune de
Saint-Paul l'île de la Réunion voilà
alors moi je veux porter un témoignage
vous avez dit des choses qui m'ont
vraiment touché et qui ont percuté dans
mon quotidien par rapport à la violence
euh le chômage c'est quelque chose qui
qui qui est très bien répendu on a
affaire à des citoyens qui ne
comprennent pas toujours ce ce non
partage des contrats et ce non partage
des logements voilà pour cette première
journée du congrès des mer de France
consacré aux élus d'outreem et à leur
problématiqu sur le terrain c'est la fin
de cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
rendez-vous demain à 11h public sénna
sera en direct de la Porte de Versailles
à Paris avec une émission spéciale qui
va décrypter les enjeux de ce 105e
congrès des maires de France et puis
continuez à suivre l'actualité politique
et parlementaire sur notre site internet
publicsena.fr je vous souhaite une très
bonne soirée sur Public
[Musique]
Sénat